[Music]
one summer evening in 335 BCE Alexander
the Great was arresting by the Danube
River after a day of fighting the
Scythian tribes when a band of strangers
approached his camp Alexander had never
seen anything like these tall
fierce-looking warriors with huge golden
neck rings and colorful cloaks so he
invited them to feast with him they
proudly said they were quel toy or Celts
who came from the faraway Alps Alexander
asked what they feared the most in the
world hoping they would say him they
laughed and said they feared nothing at
all this is one of the earliest stories
about the ancient Celts while we don't
know where the first Celts came from by
Alexander's time they had spread across
Europe from Asia Minor in the East to
Spain and the Atlantic islands of
Britain and Ireland in the West the
Celts were never one unified Empire and
they didn't build cities or monuments
instead they were hundreds of
independent tribes who spoke the same
language each had its own warrior King
and religious center the tribes fought
each other as enthusiastically as they
fought their enemies few armies could
stand up to them somewhat unusually for
the time the Celts believed in
reincarnation that they would be reborn
on earth to live and feast and fight
again which may have contributed to
their fearlessness in battle some of
them fought naked scoffing at their
enemy's armor the greatest trophy a
Celtic Warrior could possess was the
severed head of a foe they preserved
these heads in jars of cedar oil and
showed them to guests who visited their
homes Celtic warriors were so valued in
the ancient world that foreign kings
often hired them as mercenary soldiers
to serve in their armies
but the Celts were much more than just
warriors among them were many skilled
craftsmen artists and great poets called
bards the bards sang of the brave deeds
of their ancestors and praised the
accomplishments of warrior kings and
composed biting satires about cowardly
or selfish leaders the Celts worshipped
many gods and priests known as druids
oversaw this worship anyone could become
a druid but the training required many
years of study and memorization the
Druids were not allowed to record any of
their teachings in writing druids
supervised drah lidge's practices and
sacrifices to the gods but they were
also teachers healers judges and
scientists they were so respected that
they could step between warring tribes
in the middle of a battle and call an
end to the fighting no Celt would dare
to harm a druid or question their
decisions in the second century BCE the
Romans began to encroach on Celtic
territory conquering the tribes of
northern Italy rather than unite against
the Roman legions in response to this
defeat the Celts maintained their tribal
divisions the tribes of Spain fell soon
after in the first century BCE Julius
Caesar marched his armies across France
using bribery threats and lies to turn
tribes against each other only in the
closing days of this great war did the
Celts unite against their common enemy
under the leadership of King / King
jetter ik's but it was too late
countless warriors and their families
died or were enslaved as the Romans
conquered France protected by the
surrounding waters the Celtic tribes of
Britain and Ireland were the last
holdouts when the Romans finally invaded
Britain the Queen Boudicca United her
tribe in a revolt after her husband was
killed she almost succeeded in driving
the Roman legion
out of Britain before dying as she led a
final battle against the enemy by the
end of the first century CE II Ireland
alone far out at sea remained
unconquered by Rome they're the ways of
the ancient Celts survived untouched by
the outside world
long after Rome itself lay in ruins who
were these ancient Celtic druids that
warriors so feared and respected travel
back in time to centuries to join the
druid cama in her village as she goes
about her daily duties
[Music]